Okay, now let's look at some code.
It's going to take us 2 kernels to be able to run this.
The first one is going to be an initialization kernel that we run once,
and then we're going to show our iteration kernel that we're going to run on every iteration of the loop.
Now the initialization kernel is extremely simple.
It's just a map over all the vertices,
and it's simply going to initialize the vertex array.
So we get the vertex array as an argument, we know how long it is,
and we know which vertex is the starting vertex.
All we're going to do is calculate a global index for our particular thread,
and then if our thread is the starting vertex, then we're going to set its depth to 0.
Otherwise, we're going to set it to negative 1,
and here we're going to designate negative 1 as our not visited value.
Okay. This is very simple. Easy map operation.
The more interesting one is the one we'll show next,
which is the kernel that we're going to run on every iteration.